mettre des mots et des images sur une
période difficile
le musée royal de l'ontario présente une
exposition d'oeuvres fait part des
enfants pendant la pandémie le musée en
a reçu plus de 2000 des dessins des
peintures des chansons et même des
sculptures considérés dans leur ensemble
ces oeuvres dresse un portrait de la
pandémie vue par les enfants les jeunes
et son annexe ça et vend pas caché
comment est simple si plusieurs oeuvres
ont pour thème la crise sanitaire
certaines font écho à d'autres moments
marquants de 2020 comme le mouvement
black like the matters cette jeune
artiste auront 3 a peint un autoportrait
pendant les manifestations at the
news mais
[Musique]
l'expérience de many people avec mais
c'est la première fois que le musée
royal de l'ontario expose des oeuvres
soumises par le grand public une
soixantaine de création seulement ont
été sélectionnés pour être exposé en
salle mais toutes les autres sont
disponibles en ligne c'est le cas d'une
photo envoyée par cette adolescente nos
perspectives sont quelquefois pas
toujours entendus et c'est très
important que l'on utilise notre allons
pour faire des choses comme cela une
introspection qui interpelle visiblement
les adultes
le musée espère que cette exposition
gratuite permettra d'encourager les
enfants à y remettre les pieds c'est une
expérience chorale qu'on a tous vécu
et d'avoir quelque chose à partager dans
une espace avec de leurs faits par les
enfants je pense que c'est bien
l'exposition est présentée jusqu'au 27
mars ici elle me dit radio canada
toronto